bien monsieur le rapporteur général
monsieur le rapporteur spécial ce
président de chambre
mesdames messieurs où il est le
président il est en face de moi voilà je
cherchais je l'avais vu là est en face
mesdames Messieurs mes chers collègues
nous procédons donc aujourd'hui à une
audition pour suite à donner à l'enquête
de la Cour des comptes réalisé à la
demande de notre commission en
application de l'article 58 2 de la loi
organique relative aux lois de finances
sur la scolarisation des élèves
allophones
la scolarisation rapide et massive de
jeunes Ukrainiens au printemps 2022 a
été considéré comme un succès mais elle
a aussi souligné certaines fragilité du
dispositif d'accueil des élèves
allophones c'est-à-dire dans la langue
maternelle évidemment n'est pas le
français or la plus complète analyse sur
ce sujet remonter après de 15 ans dans
un contexte de croissance continue du
nombre d'élèves allophones scolarisés en
France
il manquait donc une étude consolidée
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
Commission de des Finances à la demande
de son rapport spécial Gérard Longuet a
commandé à la Cour des comptes une
enquête sur le sujet nous recevons donc
aujourd'hui monsieur nassermeda
président de la troisième chambre de la
Cour des comptes qui nous présentera les
principales conclusions de cet enquête
pour nous éclairer sur le sujet et
répondre aux observations de la Cour
sont également présents madame Rachel
Marie pradaï Duval
chef de service de l'Instruction
publique et de l'action pédagogique à la
Direction Générale de l'Enseignement
scolaire et Monsieur Daniel auverlo qui
est donc recteur de Créteil
après avoir entendu la Cour des comptes
le rapporteur spécial Gérard Longuet
présentera les principaux enseignements
qu'il attiré de cette enquête puis je
laisserai évidemment la parole à nous
inviter et à l'issue de débats je
demanderai au monde de la commission des
finances leur accord pour publier
l'enquête remise par la Cour des comptes
je rappelle à chacun que cette audition
est ouverte à la presse et retransmise
sur le site internet du Sénat je laisse
tout de suite la parole à Monsieur
nassermeda peut-être pour environ une
trentaine de minutes très bien merci
merci Monsieur président messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs j'ai le plaisir de venir
présenter devant vous le rapport de la
Cour sur la scolarisation des élèves
allophones
ce document vous a été transmis dans le
cadre vous l'avez dit de la demande
d'enquête de la part du président de la
commission des finances du Sénat en
application de l'article 58 2 de la loi
organique du premier août 2001
les contours de cette enquête ont été
précisées dans la lettre de cadrage que
le premier président vous adressé le 20
avril 2022 je vous remercie encore
monsieur le président de l'organisation
de cette audition dont je me réjouis je
tiens tout d'abord à vous présenter
l'équipe qui m'entoure donc à Magog
conseiller maître président de section
Philippe Rousselot qui est le nouveau
président de section qui va suivre
l'enseignement scolaire à côté de lui
Jean-Christophe Poton qu'on s'y mettre
qui était contre rapporteur de cette
enquête à ma droite la cheville ouvrière
de cette enquête conseiller Med
jérogibert qui sera le plus à même de
répondre aux nombreuses questions que
vous aurez peut-être à nous poser et
Gwenaëlle Roudot conseil référendaire en
service extraordinaire qui est le
nouveau responsable du secteur
Enseignement scolaire au sein de la
troisième chambre voilà pour l'équipe
qui m'entoure alors l'enjeu
d'intégration de ces jeunes et en effet
un enjeu majeur pour éviter qu'il ne va
pénaliser par rapport aux enfants de la
même génération ce sujet bénéficie
aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président d'une actualité particulière
compte tenu de la présence sur le
territoire de nombreux jeunes réfugiés
Ukrainiens
l'enquête n'a pas eu pour objet de
traiter l'ensemble des élèves ne parlant
pas ou mal français à l'entrée en
maternelle ou encore de scolarité mais
bien de se concentrer conformément à la
définition reconnue sur le plan
international et par le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale sur les élèves
allophones nouvellement arrivé sur le
territoire ea na comme nous disons
habituellement c'est-à-dire nouvellement
arrivé en France et dont la langue
maternelle n'est pas le français
nous sommes bien conscients que le sujet
aurait pu être beaucoup plus large s'il
avait fallu appréhender tous les enfants
qui rencontrent des difficultés de
maîtrise de la langue française un jeune
est considéré comme Eana quand en
arrivant sur le territoire il a des
besoins éducatifs particuliers dans
l'apprentissage du français mis en
évidence par un test de positionnement
au cours de l'année scolaire 2020-2021
dernier chiffre connu 64 564 Eana ont
été scolarisés en école élémentaire en
collège ou en lycée leur nombre a très
probablement diminué jusqu'en mars 2022
du fait de la crise sanitaire puis a
augmenté depuis cette date compte tenu
des enfants réfugiés Ukrainiens
scolarisés
23% des ena n'ont pas été scolarisés
antérieurement ou très peu dans leur
pays d'origine
l'obligation d'instruction s'applique
désormais dans notre pays pour les
jeunes de trois saisons et une
obligation de formation existe de 16 à
18 ans pouvant passer par un emploi un
stage ou un apprentissage
elle est applicable pour ceux qui quel
que soit leur statut ou leur nationalité
sont présents en France elle s'applique
donc naturellement aux Enna arrivant sur
le territoire et dont la langue
maternelle n'est pas le français
cette question est particulièrement
sensible outre-mer en Guyane et à
Mayotte compte tenu de la démographie et
des flux migratoires dans ces régions
dans un contexte d'existence de
plusieurs langues maternelles autre que
le français
pour donner à ses élèves les mêmes
chances de réussite que les autres il
est nécessaire de prévoir un soutien en
particulier linguistique en tout cas
dans une phase initiale
l'objectif est dans la logique de
l'école inclusive d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour vous dire que la troisième
chambre va travailler sur la
problématique plus large de l'école
inclusive donc nous aurons sans doute si
vous le voulez bien échanger sur ce
sujet de l'école inclusive donc cet
objectif
dans cette logique de l'école inclusive
qui s’insert progressivement le plus
rapidement possible dans un cursus
ordinaire les Arna tout en étant inscrit
dans une classe ordinaire effectue ainsi
le début de scolarité dans une unité
spécifique les unités pédagogiques pour
élèves allophones nouvellement arrivé
upe dosa pour un maximum d'un an ou deux
ans
sinon s'ils sont non scolarisés
antérieurement
ils en sortent de manière progressive au
fur et à mesure notamment de leur
progrès en langue française le coût de
ce dispositif spécifique et d'environ
180 millions d'euros en supplément de
celui d'un élève en classe ordinaire
de la cour qui a comporté de nombreuses
visites de terrain dans les rectorats et
un parentonnage international en
Allemagne et en Italie a montré que le
système en place avait des mérites mais
qui souffrait de plusieurs difficultés
en 2020-2021
91% des ena en bénéficié d'un
accompagnement linguistique
dans 62% en U pe2a ordinaire 8% en up2a
pour les non scolarisés antérieurement
19% inclus en cursus ordinaire avec un
soutien linguistique et 2% soutenu par
un autre dispositif
la baisse du nombre de àena pendant la
crise sanitaire n'a pas entraîné de
diminution du nombre du pe2a dans cette
même période ce qui a contribué à une
insertion rapide des réfugiés Ukrainiens
dont le dispositif
le système parvient souvent à une bonne
personnalisation du parcours lors de la
première année ce qui est indispensable
compte tenu de du profil des profils
très hétérogènes
comme le montre la situation des élèves
réfugiés Ukrainiens la problématique est
par exemple très différente pour les ena
normalement scolarisés avant leur
arrivée en France que pour ceux qui
n'ont pas été scolarisés antérieurement
il est de ce point du regrettable que
les données statistiques sur leur nombre
et les effets et les délais
d'affectation soient produites de
manière imparfaite et irrégulière
une première difficulté
réside dans l'adaptation de l'offre aux
besoins
jusqu'en 2020 les délais d'affectation
dans une classe se sont allongées
notamment dans les zones les plus
concernées par les flux migratoires le
plus préoccupant et le nombre non
marginal d'élèves non scolarisées dans
le secondaire au bout d'un long délai au
bout de 6 mois 3,7% des EA de collège et
6,8% de lycées ne sont pas scolarisés
il existe une difficulté de mettre en
place des dispositifs du pe2a en
primaire dans les territoires ruraux à
Habitat dispersés
après l'upe2a le soutien linguistique
n'est plus effectué dans le primaire si
ce n'est dans le cadre du fonctionnement
de la classe ordinaire
ceci contraste avec ce qui existe dans
plusieurs autres pays où le soutien
linguistique spécifique s'étend sur
plusieurs années
deuxième difficulté la formation très
insuffisante des enseignants une étude
récente de l'OCDE c'est une étude qui
date de 2018 mais dans laquelle on peut
le regretter l'Allemagne n'est pas
inclus dans cette étude
donne des résultats très préoccupants
8% des enseignants je dis bien 8% des
enseignants de notre pays se sentent
bien préparés ou très bien préparés pour
enseigner en milieu multiculturel ou
plurilingue contre 26% en moyenne dans
l'ensemble de l'OCDE
le nombre de jours de formation continue
consacré à ce sujet est en 2020-2021 de
0,26% du total dans le primaire et de
2,2% dans le secondaire soit nettement
inférieur à la proportion du nombre
d'élèves allophones même si aucune
donnée nationale n'existe en ce domaine
de nombreux enseignants en upe2a ne
disposent ne dispose pas d'une
certification en langue d'une
certification française langue seconde
le FLS
plusieurs actions ont été entreprises
pour l'accompagnement des enseignants
les centres académiques pour la
scolarisation des élèves allophones
nouvellement arrivés et des enfants
issus de famille itinérantes et de
voyageurs le Cazenave anime ces
initiatives leur mise en réseau et
cependant très largement perfectible
troisième difficulté les carences de
l'évaluation le DELF c'est à dire le
diplôme d'études en langue française
valide des compétences en langue de
communication orale et écrite les EA
peuvent le passer
cet examen est gratuit les deux
premières années de leur arrivée en
France mais son passage est facultatif
il ne constitue donc pas un indicateur
systématique de l'avancée dans
l'apprentissage de la langue ceci
permettrait pourtant une objectivation
de l'apport du dispositif des bouchons
ensuite sur un soutien pédagogique plus
précis
il inciterait à construire des
compétences de français dans différentes
disciplines scolaires et donc à une
prise en compte du FLS par d'autres
enseignants que ceux de français
comme dans les pays européens à visiter
les données d'évaluation sont très
parcellaires et parfois anciennes c'est
d'autant plus dommageable que les
difficultés initiales de ces jeunes
peuvent s'expliquer en partie par le
nombre d'élèves qui se retrouvent au
bout de compte en situation d'échec du
système scolaire
il n'existe pas en particulier de suivi
de Cortes et pourtant c'est
indispensable si on veut faire une étude
approfondie il n'y a pas d'étude de
suivi de coord des EA à partir de la
date de leur premier test de
positionnement
la question des élèves allophones de
plus de 16 ans et de moins de 6 ans
mérite d'être posée
s'agissant des EA de plus de 16 ans
l'écart important entre leur nombre et
celui des mineurs non accompagnés prises
en charge par les Conseils
départementaux
laissent penser qu'une bonne partie de
ces derniers ne bénéficient d'aucune
formation
de nombreux facteurs extérieurs à
l'éducation nationale explique cette
situation mais le dispositif du
ministère peut y contribuer il souffre
en effet d'un manque d'orientation
nationale la circulaire de 2012 est en
très floue sur le sujet aucun texte n'a
depuis précisé la politique a mené en la
matière les rectorats sont amenés de ce
fait à prendre des initiatives pour
tenter de répondre aux besoins mais sans
vision systématique et cohérente les
dispositifs sont récents insuffisants et
souvent peu inclusif il n'y a aucun
plafond du nombre maximal d'élèves dans
les upe de za dans les lycées ces
structures sont le plus souvent insérées
dans les lycées professionnels ce qui
pose le problème de l'inclusion
certaines sont en fait en réalité fermée
c'est-à-dire sans inclusion en cours
d'année ni cours commun avec des
classeurs binaires à l'exception de
l'EPS
pour les EA de moins de 6 ans
après de ce de plus de 16 ans le
ministère n'envisage pas à notre
connaissance pour le moment de
dispositif spécifique pour cette
catégorie elle considère que l'entrée
dans la langue de l'école est une
problématique commune à tous les élèves
de maternelle pourtant la question
mérite d'être posée compte tenu de ce
qui peut se pratiquer dans d'autres pays
le rapport aborde enfin la mobilisation
du ministère pour l'accueil des jeunes
réfugiés Ukrainiens
17677 jeunes élèvent ukrainiens ont été
accueillis au 24 mai 2022 dans les
écoles collèges lycée français depuis le
24 février 2022
ces chiffres sont inférieurs à ceux de
l'Allemagne sans mille et de l'Italie
57% des élèves Ukrainiens sont
scolarisés à l'école primaire 33% au
collège et 10% au lycée il a été établi
dans certains rectorats une Fastrac pour
l'inscription le jeûne peut s'inscrire
dans un établissement scolaire le plus
proche de son hébergement sans passer
par les préfectures et avant même tout
test linguistique le délai entre la
première prise de contact et
l'inscription d'établissements scolaire
a pu ainsi s'établir à deux à trois
semaines
le soutien linguistique est
principalement passé par des enseignants
itinérants rémunérés en heures
supplémentaires il a été accepté que les
élèves suivent des cours sur la
plateforme du ministère ukrainien de
l'éducation mais au sein de
l'établissement scolaire et dans la
mesure du possible en extra-scolaire
cela a pu nécessiter des adaptations
ponctuelles d'emploi du temps au 12 mai
97 enseignants réfugiés Ukrainiens sont
recrutés ou en cours de recrutement ils
sont majoritairement francophones et
enseignant en Ukraine dans diverses
disciplines
les recommandations que nous faisons et
que vous retrouvez vous retrouverez au
début du rapport répondent à ce
diagnostic notamment la fixation d'un
objectif de délai maximal pour la pardon
la fixation d'un objectif de délai
maximal pour l'accès à l'éducation d'un
ena et l'entrée dans le dispositif donc
il faut un délai un délai maximal
aujourd'hui il n'y en a pas
la mise en oeuvre dans le primaire d'un
soutien spécifique pour les EA au-delà
de la première ou des deux premières
années de présence sur le territoire le
récit ça nous semble aller dans le bon
sens la généralisation de la
certification française langue
secondaire flls pour les enseignants en
U pe2a là encore où l'évaluation
systématique du niveau en français des
ona à la sortie des upe 2A voilà les
principales recommandations que nous
avons tenues à souligner dans le cadre
de ce rapport tout en étant conscient
que ce rapport
n'épuise pas le sujet beaucoup plus
large des problématiques liées à la
maîtrise et à l'apprentissage du
français que ce soit par des élèves
français ou des élèves d'origine
étrangère nous avons concentré comme
vous l'avez compris notre rapport sur la
problématique autour de la définition
fixée par l'OCDE monsieur le Président
nous dit de manière rapide les
principales conclusions
auxquelles nous avons pu aboutir tout en
étant conscient je le redig et j'insiste
là-dessus que nous serons sans doute
amenés à revenir sur le sujet
merci monsieur le Président je vais
donner la parole à notre rapporteur
spécial Gérard Longuet
oui merci monsieur le Président
je voudrais d'abord remercier nos
invités de leur présence et surtout de
leur engagement de leur travail très
approfondi sur ce sujet difficile que
constitue l'évolution
assez spectaculaire et peut-être
différenciée de l'accueil des
nouveaux élèves allophones
ayant été scolarisé ou ne l'ayant pas
été votre rapport j'ai eu le privilège
de le parcourir le crayon à la main et
d'un véritable intérêt et va sans doute
c'est la vocation de la Cour des comptes
d'ailleurs susciter des réactions Madame
la Directrice du ministère d'éducation
nationale éclairée j'en suis persuadé
les travaux de notre commission à la
lueur de la lumière à la lumière
éclatante
d'un professionnel de terrain notre
recteur de Créteil qui a eu de
d'illustre prédécesseurs je crois
une fois qu'on a dit ça
pour les collègues qui ne sont peut-être
pas très impliqués sur ce sujet
rappelez que quantitativement c'est une
affaire en effet importante et en
évolution rapide
65000 hors ukrainiens
avaient rajouté en gros à la loge 20 000
ça fait
85000 élèves allophones
qui sont nouveaux arrivants c'est un
véritable défi quantitatif
à l'intérieur de ce défi quantitatif la
répartition est votre rapport permet de
la maîtriser
rectorat et très parlante sur la
situation
extrêmement contrastée de l'accueil des
élèves allophones il est évident que les
situations de Mayotte et de Guyane sont
des situations très très différentes de
la situation de rectorats métropolitains
nous arrivons à des chiffres qui sont de
l'ordre de 2% de nouveaux arrivants ce
qui est quand même important quand on
sait que la moyenne métropolitaine est
plutôt inférieure à 0,5% on a donc un
taux qui est du quadruple ce qui pose
évidemment un problème ce qui est
intéressant pour quelqu'un qui aime
l'aménagement du territoire
c'est que les différences par rectorat
en France métropolitaine sont également
significatives
et sont je pense qu'on va dire
inversement proportionnelle au dynamisme
démographiques des régions c'est à dire
que les régions qui sont
démographiquesment les plus importants
les plus dynamiques l'Ouest français en
particulier sont également celles qui
sont les moins concernés par
l'accueil d'élèves nouveaux arrivants à
le fun
c'est donc une un questionnement qui est
intéressant
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure l'idée
de Corse monsieur le Président vous avez
mille fois raison pour mieux connaître
notre sujet savoir pourquoi
telle ou tel région et
bénéficier de nouveaux arrivants en
proportion significativement supérieur à
tel ou tel autre région et l'explication
qui vient à l'esprit mais je vous pose
la question je la pose tant à
l'éducation nationale
qu'à la Cour des comptes n'y a-t-il pas
tout simplement un phénomène de
capillarité c'est à dire que on va là où
on a des parents et on a donc un effet
cumulatif ce qui a un immense avantage
pour le travail prévisionnel c'est qu'on
peut partir du principe que le les
besoins seront d'autant plus forts que
nous avons déjà une présence
d'élèves allophones nouveaux arrivants
et que par conséquent la tendance sera
sans doute de renforcer cette première
cette répartition ce qui permet
je parle avec conditionnel et je vous
pose la question d'avoir une vision plus
prospective
ce qui apparaît très clairement dans
votre intervention le Président c'est
que vous trouvez que d'abord la
circulaire de 2012 comme son nom
l'indique elle a 14 ans oui c'est ça
et
13 exagérons pas et elle aurait besoin
d'être actualisé et d'être actualisé sur
des questions qui sont liées à la
d'abord et avant tout à la connaissance
statistique et au suivi des élèves la
connaissance statistique je viens de
l'évoquer c'est savoir où sont-ils et
comment vont-ils évoluer
la connaissance statistique c'est
également le suivi de corps c'est-à-dire
on sait qu'elle est en gros le niveau de
départ on ne sait pas quelle est la
situation au bout d'un an ce qui est
évidemment
ça pose problème on peut dire la vision
positive c'est de dire bon bah en un an
ils ont rattrapé au moins minimum 9
heures par semaine dans le primaire on
va
plus 12 heures pour le secondaire et les
décalages de
les décalages sont limités à deux ans je
crois par rapport à l'âge moyen du
niveau scolaire c'est c'est une
situation
qui mériterait d'être mieux mieux mieux
suivi alors nous avons les casse Naves
il y a beaucoup de d'acronymes qui sont
nouveaux alors les cassenaves c'est
c'est en fait c'est la navigation du
rectorat sur dans ce secteur là et
nous avons des moyens qui sont en effet
différenciés par rectorat on peut le
comprendre puisque la pression
démographique n'est pas la même dans
chaque rectorat on peut cependant penser
que dans les rectorats où la pression ou
la demande est très forte il y aurait un
vrai besoin de suivi
sur les arrivées et sur les performances
des différents établissements
vous avez évoqué des sujets plus
ponctuels
les moins de 6 ans
avec l'obligation de scolarisation à
partir de 3 ans la maternelle
tous les parents je suis persuadé il y
en a quelques-uns dans notre commission
savent que l'apprentissage des langues
étrangères est beaucoup plus aisées pour
avoir présidé une région bilingue
de moins en moins est là mais une région
bilingue l'expérience prouve que les
jeunes enfants ont plus de facilité à
acquérir le un langage qui n'est pas
l'heure et ils ont une facilité assez
surprenante à s'adresser dans le bon
langage au bon interlocuteur
il suffit bon
peut-être l'éducation nationale
confirmera-t-elle ou infirmera-t-elle
cela donc je ne suis pas
catastrophique ça méritait d'être mieux
suivi par les moins de 6 ans
les plus de 16 ans c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
parce que il peut y avoir de vrais
sentiments de déclassement
nous maîtrisons évidemment tous
parfaitement des langues étrangères
enfin pas suffisamment pas faitement à
l'épreuve des faits rien n'est plus
frustrant dans une négociation
internationale monsieur le Président que
de se sentir mutilé pour ne pas être en
mesure d'exprimer toutes les nuances de
sa pensée dans une langue qui n'est pas
la vôtre je pense que ce sentiment les
les plus de 16 ans doivent leur le
mesurer et avoir donc des réactions plus
compliquées plus difficiles à suivre sur
les mineurs non accompagnés vous avez
ouvert pardonnez-moi la boîte de Pandore
parce que ici vous avez beaucoup d'élus
qui ont des responsabilités
départementales et qui ont l'intime
conviction que le statut de mineur non
accompagné est un statut administratif
d'attente et ne correspond heureusement
j'ai presque envie de dire dans l'IM
majorité des cannes correspond pas à une
réalité de mineur mais j'ouvre une
parenthèse peut-être des collègues me
confirmeront ou me mentiront lorsque
nous avons des mineurs qui qui peuvent
accéder par exemple à des formations
professionnelles par l'apprentissage ça
se passe plutôt très bien ça se passe
plutôt très bien il faut une motivation
il faut un objectif précis
le c'est pas forcément vous avez évoqué
les le rôle des lycées professionnels
c'est pas forcément mauvais parce que
c'est une ça me permet une perspective
d'insertion plus rapide et bien
identifiée
la question je voudrais en fait poser
c'est
au ministère à travers les
interrogations
Président nous a
formulé c'est peut-on
c'est une façon significative améliorer
le suivi statistique alors qu'il n'y a
au fond pas d'autres obligations que le
volontariat et qu'il n'y a pas
nécessairement de réseau pour les les
nouveaux arrivants qui ne sont pas
mineurs non accompagnés ils sont pris en
charge par des familles qui jouent qui
ne jouent pas le jeu qui s'en occupe ou
qui s'en occupent pas nous avons ensuite
la grande deuxième question la grande
différence d'encadrement par rectorat
alors est-ce une différence
issue de l'expression des besoins
évidemment légitime ouais c'est une
différence par les hasards de la vie de
la rencontre entre des enseignants
volontaires puisque le volontariat joue
un rôle sur la formation professionnelle
ici à la commission des finances en ce
qui concerne la l'éducation nationale
nous avons souligné à maintes reprises
la faiblesse de la formation permanente
toute
catégories confondues avec ses débats
lancinants sur sur quel temps la
formation permanente doit-elle
être
s'impliquer c'est pas s'impliquer ce
être imputé voilà terme exact c'est
imputé
et là sur le sur cercle sur certificat
il est évident que gérer des des jeunes
des enfants
qui n'ont pas eu de formation scolaire
ou qui ont une formation scolaire dans
une culture très différente de la nôtre
je pense au problème de de l'écriture
tout simplement
c'est un sujet difficile et on aimerait
en effet qu'il y ait à la plus de
volontariat et plus de
certificats Sion de cette certification
correspondant à de vraies formations
voilà quels sont les premières
réflexions je pense que ce sujet va
susciter un vif intérêt chez nos
collègues qui prennent la parole
maintenant ou monsieur le président
c'est Madame la chef de service qui va
prendre la parole tout d'abord puis
Monsieur le Recteur
merci monsieur le rapporteur madame
monsieur le Président messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs alors
tout d'abord je
participer à cette audience sur
l'accompagnement le suivi des élèves
allophones nouvellement arrivés c'est
d'abord un sujet qui nous tient à cœur
côté Direction Générale de
l'Enseignement scolaire et je vais
commencer par dire que nous partageons
un certain nombre de constats qui ont
été portés par la cour avec laquelle
nous avons
échangé longuement et de façon de façon
multiple au cours de l'année 2022 même
si sur les propositions nous pouvons
avoir des nuances mais sans surprise je
voudrais reprendre un certain nombre de
points qui ont été qui ont été précisés
à la fois sur
une accélération et une évolution du
regard qui peuvent être des regards qui
peuvent être portés
sur ces élèves allophones depuis
quelques années à la fois avec ce qui a
été mis en œuvre
[Musique]
depuis l'année dernière avec l'arrivée
des élèves d'origine
ukrainienne et au-delà la façon dont les
vagues successives d'arriver nous ont
montré qu'il y avait une très forte
hétérogénéité dans le parcours des
jeunes qui arrivaient sur notre
territoire leurs besoins et qui
confortaient l'idée que accompagner des
élèves allophones c'est à la fois une
obligation institutionnelle mais c'est
aussi ça demande aussi un accompagnement
quasi individuel compte tenu de la
grande diversité des besoins qui
existent je voudrais aussi redire que
comme vous l'avez souligné les uns et
les autres
le contexte a très sensiblement évolué
notamment depuis 2019 avec d'une part
l'obligation d'instruction à trois ans
qui changent sensiblement la donne par
rapport à ce qu'il pouvait exister
notamment avec la fameuse circulaire de
2012 qui du coup paraît presque
archaïque et je reviendrai sur ce
contexte là compte tenu de cette
évolution et la deuxième évolution de la
liée à la loi pour une école de la
confiance de 2019 c'est la mise en place
de l'obligation de formation qui a été
rappelé par Monsieur le Président
il y a quelques minutes qui du coup
donne une possibilité pour les 16-18
d'une d'une obligation d'accompagnement
particulier différentes de ce que l'on a
dans le cadre de l'instruction mais qui
permet du coup collectivement et pas que
par l'Éducation nationale un suivi des
jeunes les plus âgés vers une capacité
d'insertion globale professionnelle
social au cœur de notre pays donc
l'ensemble de ces éléments amène
clairement à ce que l'on
se réinterroge aujourd'hui sur ce qui
peut être proposé ça a été souligné par
un certain nombre de d'éléments sur
lesquels je pourrais je pourrais revenir
et tout d'abord sur le fait que au
niveau national la question du pilotage
du réseau des cazenaves est un élément
qui a été
qui s'est montré comme étant
particulièrement sensible au printemps
2022 l'arrivée des jeunes Ukrainiens la
nécessité
impérieuse de trouver dans des temps
très courts des modalités d'accueil et
une organisation y compris avec une
territorialisation qui était très
différente de ce que l'on avait jusque
là
au niveau des élèves allophones avec des
territoires je pense notamment au sud de
la France et à l'Académie Nice qui ont
été
particulièrement sollicité ce qui n'est
pas le cas habituellement
nous a amené à renforcer le pilotage
national du réseau des cazenaves qui est
du coup
sollicité par la Direction Générale de
l'Enseignement scolaire
beaucoup plus régulièrement alors
pourquoi je rentre par ce pilotage
national c'est aussi parce que c'est une
façon de sensibiliser l'ensemble des
académies sur la nécessité d'avoir un
suivi et d'avoir des indicateurs
partagés
entre Academy et au niveau national
notamment d'un point de vue statistique
vous soulignez la difficulté d'avoir des
éléments statistiques partagés peut-être
parce que historiquement
accompagner les élèves allophones
c'était localement avec des indicateurs
spécifiques qui n'étaient pas
nécessairement toujours consolidées au
même temps et avec les mêmes critères
pour pouvoir les les regrouper au niveau
national ce qui d'ailleurs est souligné
par l'adepte le service national
statistique du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse donc cet
élément-là est un élément important
c'est travailler sur le pilotage de
l'accompagnement au niveau national et
se donner les moyens au niveau national
et au niveau territorial d'avoir des des
indicateurs qui nous permettent
d'identifier les évolutions de ce
cadre-là et ça nous amène du coup à
interroger à la fois la façon dont on va
accompagner ce que je vais le cadre
classique historique les 16 les 6-16 ans
mais aussi de regarder comment on
accompagne les moins de 6 ans et les
plus de 16 ans dans le cadre au moins de
l'obligation de formation donc ce
contexte là est un élément qui du coup
transforme à la fois le regard du
pilotage national nous amène à
réinterroger la circulaire de 2012 sur
lequel on est en train de travailler
parce qu'effectivement il y a un
caractère obsolescent compte tenu du
nouveau contexte législatif dont je
viens de parler et puis ça nous oblige
aussi à nous réinterroger y compris en
lien avec le les élèves à besoin
éducatifs particuliers et l'école
inclusive sur la façon dont on
accueille des élèves ayant des besoins
particuliers en l'occurrence des besoins
liés aux Français en langue scolaire et
en langue seconde avec des petites
nuances entre les deux et la façon dont
on désé teilles cet accompagnement
puisque l'objectif de cette
accompagnement initial renforcée c'est
aussi de rendre ces jeunes
de leur donner une autonomie dans la
suite de leur parcours et donc avec un
équilibre mais je ne doute pas que
Créteil pourra donner des exemples plus
précis donc je ne vais peut-être je vais
peut-être passer à des choses peut-être
plus élémentaires monsieur le Président
à moins que vous souhaitiez que je le
fasse dans le cadre de la réponse aux
différentes questions que vous pourriez
poser il y aura certainement des
réponses aux questions mais je vous
donne encore 5 minutes madame si vous
voulez prendre quelques questions un peu
général alors toujours
ce sur ces propos sur ces propos généra
ux donc je
vous questionner moins de 6 ans parce
que elle est assez sensible et dans le
cadre du Plan maternel qui est
lancé
par le ministre papendaye je voudrais
rappeler que pour tous les enfants de 3
à 6 ans l'école maternelle c'est l'école
aussi du langage et de l'apprentissage
du langage et monsieur le rapporteur
spécial vous l'avez souligné c'est un
moment où pour tous les enfants qui sont
sur le territoire
l'apprentissage de la langue ça maîtrise
dans le cadre de l'école qui est une
adaptation à un contexte particulier
permet
de faire progresser avec des outils au
sein de la classe ces élèves allophones
arrivant sur notre territoire ce qui
veut dire aussi que dans le cadre de la
formation des professeurs des écoles qui
interviennent en maternelle la partie de
la formation à la à l'apprentissage de
la langue avec toute la variété
d'origine des élèves qui sont accueillis
dans les classes ça fait partie des
efforts de formation continue notamment
dans le cadre des constellations du plan
français qui est un qui permet d'avoir
le développement professionnel je
continue des professeurs des écoles avec
je vous le rappelle
l'obligation d'avoir 30 heures de
formation sur le français au minimum
une fois tous les 6 ans sachant qu'il y
a aussi des formations en français sur
les autres périodes
entre entre ces grandes phases de
formation en français pour ses
professeurs des écoles donc ça c'est le
premier élément sur lequel nous
travaillons
le deuxième le deuxième élément c'est le
fait que
y compris compte tenu de l'expérience
que nous avons
observer avec l'arrivée des Ukrainiens
en mars 2022 la question de l'adaptation
des dispositifs est aussi à interroger
notamment
la question des dispositifs et de la
nécessité d'avoir une grande
fluidité vous parliez tout à l'heure des
dispositifs qui étaient fermés ou des
dispositifs ouverts je rappelle que les
up2a sont des unités normalement dans
lesquelles un élève n'est pas inscrit en
U po2a sauf s'il n'a jamais été ou s'il
n'a que peu été scolarisé auparavant
mais c'est un dispositif qui doit faire
qui est un sas d'aller-retour entre une
classe ordinaire où on est dans une
classe avec d'autres
jeunes
élèvent collégiens lycéen de son niveau
scolaire mais c'est un refuge pour avoir
un apprentissage particulier sur la
langue française et donc normalement on
n'est pas à 100% dans ces unités on est
bien inscrit dans une classe ordinaire
et on bénéficie d'heures spécifiques
donc cette question d'avoir des unités y
compris avec des unités que je vais
qualifier sans mur et en réseau qui
permettent d'en des territoires
peu denses d'offrir malgré tout un
accompagnement adapté ça fait partie des
expériences qui ont été menées pour
l'accueil des Ukrainiens et qui sont
sans doute à renforcer à la fois en
s'appuyant sur des personnels qui ont
particulièrement été formé à
l'apprentissage du français en langue
scolaire mais aussi en sortant des
dispositifs du coup peuvent être
réducteurs en termes de capacité
d'accompagnement et ça va me permettre
de finir ce propos introductif par la
formation des professeurs nous
travaillons aussi sur le repérage des
professeurs qui ont une formation sans
forcément avoir une certification en
français langue scolaire y compris pour
valoriser ce parcours et ses compétences
là dans le cadre de la VAE pour qu'ils
aient une certification qui leur
permettent du coup d'être
identifiable par
leur académie et par les services qui
mettent en place de l'accompagnement
pour les élèves allophones et surtout de
bien différencier la façon dont on se
forme et le fait que des compétences qui
ont été acquises par la pratique de
l'accueil en classe ordinaire d'élèves
allophones
ces compétences doivent pouvoir être
valorisées et valider dans le cas des
Acquis de l'Expérience j'allais dire
comme tous les professionnels
sur le territoire dans le cas d'une
certification dédiée pour la
spécialisation et valoriser pour au sein
des cazenaves quand les besoins se
ressentent merci merci madame Monsieur
le Recteur la parole pour nous donner
votre expérience de terrain
merci monsieur le Président des sujets
étaient très intéressant par le rapport
de la Cour des comptes et à nous avions
eu des échanges naturellement et la
réfection a été très riche je suis
accompagné de Monsieur Daniel Guillaume
qui est le responsable du Cazenave et le
cadenas dans laquelle il Créteil c'est
une véritable industrie puisque
d'ailleurs c'est combien d'élèves le
cadavre on est à 6000 6500 à peu près
pour l'académie de Créteil
alors moi je voudrais rebondir sur 8
points en total conquête mentarité avec
ce qu'a dit Rachel Barry prazay Duval
mais en vous livrant quelques réflexions
d'observation de terrain puisque s'il
est bien compris c'est le sens de ma
présence ici
alors le premier point et
plus on commence jeune apprentissage du
français et plus c'est facile et puis
c'est facile c'est pour ça que pour ma
part je ne suis pas persuadé que en
toute six ans il soit vraiment
nécessaire d'avoir des structures
dédiées moi ce que je vois dans les dans
les écoles de la calyps Créteil dans les
écoles maternelles c'est que le bain
langage le travail du maître
systématiquement sur le vocabulaire sur
la compréhension la lecture des comptes
répétées tout ça a fait que nous avons
des enfants qui progressent très très
vite et puis qui progresse d'autant plus
vite que le jeu avec les autres est un
moment d'échange de langage donc ça
c'est la première observation
la deuxième observation que je voulais
faire c'est que
toute sa question commence quand on sort
de l'upe2a
c'est à dire que
nos élèves sont bien quand ils sont dans
l'up2a ils ont un étayage en français
ils sont inclus de manière variable à
l'intérieur des classes et peut-être
qu'on pourra revenir sur le beau
variable là où ça se complique c'est sur
ce qui se passe quand il sortait en
particulier en collège ils ont fait deux
ans ils se retrouvent en quatrième ou en
troisième et la question c'est que ils
ont pas forcément complètement le niveau
en langue écrites de leurs camarades
mais à partir de là la question qui se
pose c'est comment nos professeurs
prennent-ils en compte cette différence
chez nos élèves
certains la prennent en compte d'autres
apprennent moins en compte ce qui peut
est fait qu'on peut avoir des élèves de
très bonnes volonté mais qui évaluait
uniquement sur de l'écrit et sans regard
particulier et bien se retrouve avec des
notes très faibles ce qui d'ailleurs en
termes de motivation de même de
perception de ce qui sont etc va avoir
une conséquence et comme l'affectation
lycée en particulier
c'est-à-dire qu'elle repose sur les
notes et bien on peut avoir là une
double peine c'est-à-dire des élèves qui
n'ont pas tout à fait le niveau des
autres qui pour autant s'ils étaient
dans leur langue d'origine pour être
très très bien réussir oui c'est
professionnel mais qui vont se retrouver
dans un autre lycée que celui demandait
et dans d'autres filières que celle
demandée
et là il y a peut-être effectivement eu
une entrée à avoir de troisième point
c'est sur les 16 18 ans
sur SS 18 ans n'est confronté à
l'urgence
avec des jeunes qui ont besoin de
s'insérer rapidement dans la vie et puis
d'avoir un métier et donc là c'est
compliqué parce que il faut à la fois
leur apprendre le français courant mais
aussi leur apprendre à français de
spécialité professionnelle dans le
domaine par exemple du bâtiment ou de la
Restauration il y a des vrais besoins je
pense que là dessus il y a un sujet
qu'on n'a pas encore forcément
complètement travaillé on a des marges
de progrès c'est l'apprentissage
pour ces jeunes là en lien avec en lien
avec les entreprises
le
quatrième point que je voudrais
souligner c'est que la qualité crétin
n'est pas une académie uniforme j'ai
deux départements hyper urbains avec un
établissement scolaire tous les 400
mètres et un département qui fait moitié
à lui seul la moitié de l'Île-de-France
qu'à Seine-et-Marne donc le traitement
des élèves allophones et bien c'est pas
le même c'est à dire que nous avons en
Seine-et-Marne des élèves allophones
isolés pour lesquelles finalement
l'accompagnement ne peut pas se faire
dans les a à moins de prendre des
transports très longs etc donc là on est
sur de l'accompagnement à partir de leur
supplémentaires donnés aux enseignants
peut-être que c'est une mission à avoir
dans le cadre de la nouvelle
rémunération des enseignants qui va
s'appeler le pacte
le cinquième point que je voulais
soulever c'est celui d'un difficulté de
l'adéquation des besoins et des
dispositifs en particulier en collège
autant dans le premier degré si on a un
afflux soudain d'élèves allophones à la
limite et bien en petits straire à
intitulée de brigade enfin abrigadier
remplaçant pour le mettre sur une P2A
qu'on crée du jour au lendemain ça c'est
pas c'est pas forcément difficile en
collège c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
parce que finalement nos structures et
bien elles sont fixées pour la rentrée
au 1er septembre et donc on ne sait
jamais d'une année sur l'autre ce qui va
se passer et en particulier s'il y aura
une adéquation géographique entre
l'arrivée d'allophone et puis l'endroit
où sont nos up2a et parfois on a
l'impression d'être que c'est un peu
compliqué à gérer
le sixième point que je voulais
souligner c'est à quel point le dossier
ukrainien était particulier dérogatoire
en fait
puisque je me suis retrouvé dans des
centres d'accueil à faire la promotion
de l'école et avec des inscriptions
qu'on a faites en trois jours pour
certains et en quelques en 15 jours pour
d'autres ça a été extrêmement rapide
mais avec des élèves également un peu
particulier puisque les élèves
ukrainiens et bien ils maîtrisé
totalement les codes de l'école
totalement et à côté de ça avec un
besoin exprimé par leurs autorités qui
étaient particuliers c'est à prendre le
français c'est bien mais à condition
d'avoir une continuité pédagogique avec
Ukraine qui permettent de travailler sur
les programmes d'Ukrainiens ça a été un
moment un peu particulier
le septième point que je voulais
souligner c'est celui de la formation
avec deux types d'approches c'est à dire
que tous nos enseignants ont besoin
d'avoir une sensibilisation aux élèves a
besoin éducatifs particuliers et ça se
fait à travers les sites spé dans le
cadre d'un module d'environ 25 heures
voilà à côté de ça la maîtrise du
français dans ce monde c'est vraiment
quelque chose de compliqué c'est
vraiment c'est pas simple c'est vraiment
une spécialisation et je dirige
l'Académie dans laquelle et bien j'ai un
pourcentage d'enseignants qui chaque
année veut partir et aller vers d'autres
académies d'où ils sont originaires en
général la question qui se pose c'est
celle de leur investissement Yves
certains se disent mais je vais faire
une formation en seconde mais fait
partir dans les trois ans à quoi ça sert
puisque je ne retrouverai pas en fait
des classes des classes équivalentes et
puis le dernier point que je voulais
souligner et je vous ai bien entendu
monsieur le Président ça serait
souhaitable d'avoir effectivement un
délai entre le moment où apparent
manifestent son attention que son enfant
aille à l'école de la République et puis
le moment d'affectation dans la réalité
on voit que toutes les circonstances que
j'ai développées font que c'est
extrêmement difficile d'avoir une sorte
de délai contractuel qui nous imposerait
de ce scolariser à partir d'un moment ou
alors à ce moment-là on dit en scolarise
et puis on n'a pas disponible
d'accompagnement ce qui pourrait être de
nature totalement contre-productif voilà
les huit fois que je voulais souligner
mais je crois que Daniel Guillot Borda 3
de son côté
bien si vous le permettez en effet donc
ça serait concernant la le moment de la
scolarisation le suivi et puis un point
particulier sur les plus de 16 ans
concernant cette difficulté à scolariser
on doit distinguer le premier et le
second degré dans le premier degré la
famille va à la mairie ensuite l'enfant
est scolarisé dans l'école de proximité
et est évaluée ensuite et donc il y a
pas de délai dans le second degré on
commence par le rendez-vous d'évaluation
et c'est là que les délais s'instaure
alors quelles évolutions sont possibles
à cet égard c'est en effet assez
complexe on a vu avec les élèves
Ukrainiens qui étaient bien scolarisés
antérieurement mais qui ont une langue
éloignée de la nôtre ce qui est quand
même une difficulté que l'accueil dans
les classes ordinaires a eu lieu
donc bon là il y a une difficulté un
point que je veux que je veux mentionner
que je n'ai pas vu apparaître mais sans
doute tout ne peut pas y figurer dans le
rapport de la Cour des comptes et ça
concerne pour le coup également le
premier degré c'est le cas des enfants
qui vivent dans des bidons villes
et dont beaucoup sont allophones et là
leur repérage et tout le travail de de
rapprochement et de raccommodation avec
l'école et est un enjeu sérieux à
Créteil on les évalue environ à 2000
c'est pas négligeable très peu d'entre
eux sont scolarisés donc là c'est un
chantier qui je crois ne doit pas être
négligé le second point concernant le
suivi de ses élèves
en dépit de la circulaire de 2012 qui
prône l'inclusion on a de fait un
système qui est concentré sur la
première année où les deux premières
années scolarisation avec des
difficultés d'inclusion sur lesquelles
on pourra revenir si vous le souhaitez
il y a un consensus scientifique sur le
fait que la langue de communication peut
s'acquérir en gros dans les six mois la
langue de scolarisation celle qui est
difficile d'accès y compris pour
certains de nos élèves francophones ça
peut aller jusqu'à 6 ou 7 ans donc
concentrez tous les moyens sur un à deux
ans c'est une démarche qui pose question
et donc je pense que nous avons à
réfléchir sur un suivi plus longitudinal
pédagogiquement dans desa et également
dans les classes ordinaires alors avec
ces questions de formation qu'on a
commencé à ouvrir et où pour le coup la
situation des Ukrainiens a été un moment
intéressant puisque des enseignants de
classe ordinaires ont découvert que des
élèves allophones avaient des aptitudes
scolaires
ce qui ne réalise pas toujours en raison
de l'obstacle linguistique mais ça ça
réclame une analyse et un travail
particulier le troisième point sur
lequel je me permettrais d'apporter
quelques précisions c'est en effet la
question des plus de 16 ans
il me semble avoir lu dans le rapport à
un moment donné le fait que la majorité
des Etna de plus de 16 ans serait des
mineurs non accompagnés je pense que
c'est inacte en tout cas à la lumière de
ce que nous voyons il y a beaucoup
d'élèves de profil parfaitement
scolaires qui intègre des aliés et qui
des réussissent d'excellentes études et
on est en train de le voir aussi avec
nos élèves Ukrainiens où là la question
qui se pose en effet c'est celle du plus
bref délai dont il disposent notamment
pour passer le baccalauréat avec les
preuves anticipée de français en
première qui les met en difficulté mais
par exemple pour les élèves Ukrainiens
on réfléchit à des modes d'accès à
l'enseignement supérieur qui n'implique
pas nécessairement de passer par le
baccalauréat français
je pense que c'est une réflexion
intéressante
concernant soit les mineurs non
accompagnés soit les élèves en effet qui
n'ont pas un profil scolaire ou qui ont
une faible scolarisation je rejoins tout
à fait le recteur de Créteil sur le fait
que les conduire vers l'apprentissage et
quelque chose d'important et
d'intéressant c'est quelque chose que
nous sommes en train de de construire
avec l'appui de moyens européens en
particulier et là je me permets de
mentionner au passage que le recours
extrêmement complexe pour ne pas dire
sophistiqué au moyen européen que nous
avons dû mettre en œuvre était lié à la
limitation des moyens dont on disposait
pour les accompagner dans l'enseignement
secondaire pour ceux pour lesquels
c'était pertinent notamment du côté
professionnel et ça pose ensuite
d'autres questions alors celles vous le
mentionnez de la question de
l'évaluation de l'orage et puis aussi
une possible clarification disons des
conditions de régularisation
qui se pose qui se pose à tous et à ce
moment-là la problématique des 16-18 ans
se prolonge par celle des jeunes majeurs
et de l'accompagnement qui peut leur
être leur être proposé
voilà merci merci monsieur Guillaume
de tout évidence
l'éducation dès qu'on rentre dans un
dossier éducation nationale on rentre
dans un monde compliqué ou en tout cas
compliqué pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas et
juste une audition ne permet pas
ne sont pas tous au niveau de Gérard
Longuet sur la question éducation
nationale si je puis dire et donc c'est
sans doute très difficile d'intervenir
dans ce débat je pense qu'on a fait la
réuni des personnes qui
comment dire donne des points de vue le
point de vue de l'administration et le
point de vue du terrain alors c'est sûr
que pour nous le terrain ça nous aide
quoi d'ailleurs qu'on voit bien les
complexités et les questions locales
qu'il faut qu'il faut résoudre et ça
nous aide un peu à mieux comprendre
l'ensemble du sujet monsieur le
rapporteur général
donc je suis le premier cobaye monsieur
le Président parce qu'effectivement je
ne connais pas je ne suis pas un
spécialiste donc je vais me jeter à
l'eau je vais d'abord remercier à la
fois la cour le ministère
dans ces différents niveaux de
responsabilité
centrale et sur le travail qui est fait
par le rectorat moi j'aurais quelques
questions
enfin interrogation on va dire plutôt de
porter général et rapide je m'interroge
donc sur le cette espèce de double
difficulté qui touche les enfants de
moins de 6 ans et de plus de 16 ans
autant je pense que jusqu'à la à l'école
à l'entrée dans l'école maternelle ça
relève plutôt des familles avec parfois
des difficultés vous l'avez dit quand
les enfants sont dans des bidonvilles
mais pour tout vous dire je vais donner
un regard de terrain quand on a des
enfants qui ne sont pas scolarisés
parfois chez des gens du voyage c'est
extrêmement complexe et pour moi ça
obéit de la même logique à la même
logique et je pense que l'État n'est pas
assez fort pour
contraindre à la scolarisation parce que
je continue de penser que la
scolarisation est le premier facteur et
vecteur d'intégration pour les enfants
d'abord mais aussi pour leur famille
le deuxième sujet c'est les plus de 16
ans parce que en fait on voit que à ce
moment-là je pense que il est pas tout à
fait normal que l'État soit dans une
zone
plus floue si je danse dans ce qui
concerne ses responsabilités
d'autant que ça concerne et dans les
deux cas d'ailleurs les moins de 6 ans
entre 3 et 6 ans et les plus de 16 ans
avant la majorité ça concerne d'abord
l'état sur l'éducation mais également il
y a un jeu avec les collectivités
territoriales on peut penser
essentiellement là je dirais aux régions
pour les plus de 16 ans et aux communes
et puis dernière
interrogation de Société générale c'est
lorsque vous soulignez le problème de la
formation
insuffisante en tous les cas dans quand
on est en dessous de 10% c'est-à-dire
ouais c'est on voit bien que là il y a
un gros problème alors il est peut-être
aussi lié à la difficulté d'appréhender
les effectifs selon les régions donc
on nous a dit un moment que l'éducation
nationale était un mammouth donc je peux
comprendre que il soit parfois plus
difficile de réagir
enfin très rapidement mais il y a enfin
il y a sur ce sujet une je pense une
vraie difficulté qui enfin je voudrais
savoir peut-être dans dans votre
répartition de quelle manière
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on pourrait considérer qu'il y
a une tendance un peu lourde
à privilégier pour favoriser
l'intégration vous avez bien expliqué au
début de votre propos la difficulté
lorsqu'on est dans des zones d'habitat
peu dense
on imagine bien si vous avez une famille
par-ci par-là d'abord ils sont très
isolés est-ce que est-ce que ça peut
être un avantage si autour il y a une
communauté
d'habitants et que l'enseignant même
s'il y a peu d'enfants est-ce que c'est
facilitateur j'ai quelques doutes mais
voilà je moi je pose des questions je
est-ce que on observe à l'aune de ce
qu'on voit en France ou dans des pays
voisins une comment dirais-je plutôt une
priorité sur la manière d'organiser
l'accueil de ces enfants puisque je le
redis je pense que l'essentiel et qu'il
réussisse
dans la vie moi je me souviens très bien
avoir eu il y a quelques années dans
l'école publique dans laquelle était mes
enfants maternel enfin en primaire en
élémentaire un enfant qui venait de
mémoire de Syrie en tant que réfugiés
qui arrivait qui parlait pas un mode
français qui à la fin de l'année a
terminé 1er de la classe donc c'est pas
c'est pas très ancien tout ça
merci Monsieur Votre général arrangé une
satisfaction je dois vous le dire c'est
que j'ai l'impression que mes collègues
sont un peu comme moi c'est à dire on
dit peut-être à du mal à rentrer dans
dans ce débat j'ai deux demandes de
prise de parole ce qui est relativement
faible et bien sûr le
rapporteur spécial moi je n'ai quand
même eu une remarque en vous écoutant
c'est que derrière ce très beau mot
d'alophone j'ai fait du grec je me
régale bon mais en fait ça recoupe des
choses très différentes et que même
mettre dans le même sujet finalement
l'Ukraine et les allophones de manière
générale c'est pas forcément très
judicieux parce que effectivement ce que
j'ai bien compris me semble-t-il c'est
que la relation à l'enseignement dans le
pays d'origine est une question
fondamentale et que en fonction de cela
évidemment l'approche et la façon de
traiter des sujets et plus ou moins
facile voilà vous me direz si j'ai bien
compris mais c'est à peu près ce que
j'imaginais alors je vais laisser le
l'important spécial je vais lui demander
peut-être d'attendre les deux trois
questions et de plutôt venir en à la
suite si
ben non pas en voiture balai mais non
un esprit de synthèse c'est le Ministre
Jérôme Bacher
merci monsieur le président
première question c'est est-ce qu'il y a
une différence de traitement des élèves
allophones suivant l'enseignement
public et l'enseignement privé
j'ai pu le constater très humblement sur
la fée ukrainienne où on a vu une
capacité
ici ou là plus ou moins grande à
accueillir à bien accueillir pas
uniquement à dire bon bah oui vous êtes
des réfugiés
c'est bien de cela dont il s'agit
et donc bon vous êtes malheureux non
c'est de vraiment de les prendre en
charge et de faire en sorte que les uns
ou les autres progressent est-ce que il
y a un sujet aujourd'hui sur le
traitement des allophones est-ce que
parfois dans le mot allophone on ne met
pas évidemment beaucoup de catégories il
y a la catégorie très aisée je veux dire
les voyageurs internationaux
et puis ceux qui sont plutôt dans une
difficulté une immigration plus
difficile il faut le dire il faut
assez clairement pour pouvoir bien
traiter l'affaire
sur cette immigration plus difficile il
y a le sujet aussi de l'intégration en
dehors de l'école parce que évidemment
comme bien souvent est-ce que l'école ne
parle pas qu'à l'école
et le principe d'intégration et de
langage
moi je le vois sur les iup2a que je suis
le collège dans l'un des collèges dans
laquelle je siège au conseil
d'administration c'est un sujet
particulièrement important on y est tous
très attentif mais on voit bien aussi la
difficulté sur ces élèves qui souvent ne
sont pas stables au sens
la résidence et on a ce sujet
d'intégration aussi parce qu'on fait un
peu comme si les élèves un peu comme
partout on arrive on rentre en 6e et
puis on arrive jusqu'en troisième et
puis on va au lycée de quartier etc or
ils arrivent parfois dans un cada dans
un Oda dans lequel l'intégration est
déjà compliquée pour les parents sans
compter évidemment et vous le savez tous
pour ceux qui traitent de la demande
d'asile ont un récit
et donc un parcours de vente d'asile qui
est parfois compliqué
très difficile humainement est-ce que ça
c'est suffisamment pris en compte le
fait que ces élèves sont dans un cada et
puis vont être placés dans une ville
différente trois mois après donc pas une
année scolaire le fait est-ce que vous
prenez assez en compte le fait que
l'année scolaire n'est pas forcément le
rythme un certain nombre de d'élèves
allophones
merci Jérôme Thierry Cosic
merci monsieur le Président merci
également à la Cour des comptes pour
cette exposé je voulais pas forcément
poser poser une question et plutôt à
partir d'un témoignage j'ai eu j'ai
connaissance donc dans le département de
la Sarthe d'une situation particulière
qui a été
la suite du départ d'afavganiston et
l'arrivée massive sur un territoire de
famille de famille afghane avec une
trentaine de d'enfants enfin d'élèves
qui ont été accueillis dans les
établissements scolaires d'une petite
commune
la difficulté c'était ma question s'il y
en a une elle se tourne plutôt vers
l'éducation nationale sur lequel j'ai le
sentiment au regard de cette expérience
que les moyens aujourd'hui ne sont pas
alloués pour accueillir ces élèves
j'en veux pour exemple
de mémoire c'est une trentaine de
d'élèves qui sont arrivés dans une école
où il y a une centaine d'élèves donc
c'est dire il y avait si un peu plus il
y avait cyclass
une équipe enseignante très soudée qui
était là depuis de nombreuses années et
au bout d'un an après des alertes
répétées auprès d'éducation nationale
l'absence de moyens nous avons cinq
enseignants sur 6 qui ont demandé leur
mutation et donc aujourd'hui ma question
était plutôt étaient plutôt celle là
c'est de savoir si aujourd'hui on est en
capacité
si l'éducation nationale est en capacité
de répondre en fait à
ces demandes spécifiques et
l'accompagnement qui est dédié pour ces
pour ses enfants merci merci Thierry
Daniel Daniel broyer
merci monsieur le Président et merci des
de ce rapport et de la présentation
faite par les intervenants je voulais
aussi moi partir d'un témoignage
personnel pour évoquer un doute sur la
question du recensement des élèves
allophones
j'ai été maire d'Arcueil qui est une des
communes de l'académie de Créteil et il
y avait une classe up2a qui était
installée dans la commune voisine de
Gentilly et à l'époque il y avait huit
enfants d'Arcueil
installé dans cette classe up2a
et lorsque nous avons enfin lorsque
Monsieur le Recteur a ouvert une classe
up2a dans la commune d'Arcueil il y a eu
immédiatement 25 enfants scolarisés
pour une raison assez simple c'est que
même si il y a des distances assez
modérée
accompagner un enfant je parle
d'élémentaires accompagner un enfant en
éléments terre dans la ville voisine et
déjà beaucoup plus difficile que de
l'inscrire dans sa propre ville donc je
pense que le nombre d'enfants que nous
scolarisons en up2a est très inférieure
au nombre d'enfants qui auraient besoin
de cette scolarité en
up2a ma deuxième remarque c'est sur la
question maternelle comme Gérard Longuet
comme plusieurs l'ont dit je pense
qu'effectivement la plasticité la
capacité d'apprentissage des enfants
d'âge maternel est très grande il
n'empêche que j'ai constaté aussi c'est
l'éducation est un sujet qui m'intéresse
comme élu mais aussi professionnellement
le vocabulaire dont dispose les enfants
est quand même totalement dépendant du
milieu familial ou du milieu d'insertion
au-delà de l'école évidemment l'école
joue un rôle essentiel dans dans une
capacité de progression mais si dans le
milieu familial on ne parle pas français
ou bien d'ailleurs il y a même des gens
qui parlent français mais avec un
vocabulaire assez restreint on voit bien
que les inégalités dans la capacité de
réussite scolaire s'installe très vite
c'était ma deuxième remarque et puis
troisième remarque le sujet de la
résidence au fond c'est un sujet j'ai en
bas cher vient de l'évoquer j'ai eu à
connaître des squats très importants
vous rappelez peut-être Monsieur le
Recteur des 1000 de Cachan qui était un
énorme sujet on a scolarisé dans ma
commune des enfants qui étaient dans ce
très important squat de la commune
voisine parce qu'il fallait bien avoir
offrir une capacité de scolarisation de
tous les enfants mais j'ai eu à peut
être aussi des situations de bidonville
sur la ville voisine de Villejuif ou
dans notre ville et il y a là un
paradoxe c'est-à-dire que nous avons
d'un côté une politique de gestion de
ces bidons villes qui se traduit en
général par une évacuation au bout de
quelques temps et une déscolarisation
des enfants et j'ai acquis une certitude
c'est que sur la scolarisation des
enfants Rome ou sur la scolarisation des
enfants qui sont dans des bidonvilles la
place des associations et la stabilité
de l'école sont deux sujets majeurs
parce que les associations une capacité
de dialogue je pense notamment aux
familles Rome que les institutions n'ont
pas
et le fait de changer de vous savez
c'est la patate chaude les bidonvilles
le préfet commande une évacuation et
puis se réinstalle des fois à 500 mètres
de là des fois à 10 km de la dans des
histoires un peu compliquées qui ne sont
pas à l'ordre du jour ce matin mais il
n'empêche que la durée et la stabilité
de la scolarisation est très important
et je me rappelle d'enfants qui avaient
été viré d'un bidonville qui antérieure
enfin qui habitait en Seine-Saint-Denis
qui avait été relogé en
Seine-Saint-Denis et qui continuait à
venir à Arcueil tous les matins en
faisant plus d'une heure de transport
quotidien pour les accompagner parce que
au fond c'était la garantie d'une
réussite parce que l'insertion avait
commencé et donc je pense que cette
question
c'est hors de notre sujet mais je me
permets de le dire que laisser dans une
proximité géographique des premiers
endroits d'insertion est très important
aussi si on veut la réussite dans les
apprentissages des enfants et je termine
excusez-moi non juste une question sur
l'évaluation je ne comprends pas je le
dis je ne comprends pas qu'il n'y ait
pas une évaluation des progrès réalisés
pour permettre de s'interroger si les
dispositifs de renforcement des
apprentissages en français doivent être
poursuivis plus long plus longuement et
j'entends ce que dit monsieur Guillaume
personnellement j'avais ce sentiment
c'était nécessaire de les poursuivre
plus longuement merci Daniel donc
Christian BIAC a droit à une
demi-intervention
merci monsieur le Président
intéressant moi je ferai quelques
remarques puis une question d'abord que
la scolarisation de génoise chez quelque
chose de nouveau
il y a 100 ans dans le Massif Central je
peux garantir que 50% des élèves qui
arrivaient à l'école ne parlaient pas
c'était une réalité de quotidienne pour
les enseignants
de ces régions agricoles voilà je ferme
ne parlait pas le français et puis on a
eu les flux d'immigrations
on a vu arriver
nombre de réfugiés espagnols qui n'ont
plus ne pratiquaient pas du tout la
langue française et
il y a vu certaines difficultés de
scolarisation mais globalement oui mais
finalement ça c'est assez bien passé
parce que à côté de la scolarisation qui
est très importante qui est essentielle
c'est vrai il y a tout le reste c'est à
dire si l'école c'est une bulle
française au milieu de l'océan du notre
langue ça ne peut pas marcher et je
m'aperçois que dans mon petit village on
avait accueilli il y a quelques années
des réfugiés au moment où la guerre
assez vissé de l'Irak et
cette famille de réfugiés c'était très
très bien intégré parce que les garçons
qui avait le douzaine d'années environ
jouent au football dans leur pays et
avait été intégré par le club de
football du village il ne jouait pas au
PSG bien sûr mais le fait que il soit
avait les enfants de village dans le
club de foot et avait les enfants du
village à l'école avaient permis des
progrès exceptionnels au niveau de la
langue de la partition de la langue et
de l'intégration et donc ma question
c'est est-ce qu'au niveau de l'éducation
nationale il y a des passerelles avec
nos associations qui constituent le
terreau du vivre ensemble dans nos dans
nos communes qu'elle soit grande aux
petites ou dans nos quartiers et est-ce
qu'il y a une favorise est-ce qu'on
essaie de favoriser
l'apprentissage de la langue par par des
par l'inclusion dans l'école mais
l'inclusion aussi de la destructures
sportives de la commune
merci Christian Jean-Marie maison
merci monsieur le Président le sujet des
élèves allophones est un beau sujet
d'abord parce qu'il concerne la jeunesse
et tous ces sujets qui se tournent vers
la jeunesse nous oblige plus encore
je suis totalement d'accord avec ce que
devient de dire Christian Billac sur le
rôle des associations qui peuvent
apporter beaucoup tant il est vrai que
ces associations sont un fabuleux
vecteur de cohésion y compris pour la
jeunesse mais ma question ou c'est
plutôt une demande de précision
s'adresse à Monsieur le Recteur qui a
dit lorsqu'il a énuméré les 8 points
tout à l'heure
que
tout se passe bien
jusqu'à l'up2a et qu'ensuite les choses
changent lorsque les enfants arrivent en
quatrième ou troisième il se produit
comme une rupture peut-être n'est-ce pas
seulement que le manque de maîtrise de
la langue française en tout cas le
manque de maîtrise de l'écrit français
et je n'ai pas compris quel était votre
point de vue sur cette question
merci Jean-Marie je vais vous donner la
parole Monsieur le Recteur puisque vous
êtes tout de suite interrogé pour
répondre aux questions que vous
souhaitez la seule contrainte pour
chacun ce sera
4 5 minutes pour chaque voilà mais donc
vous prenez les questions qui vous
paraissent de votre champ de compétences
et sur lequel vous avez envie de
répondre je vais répondre en 7 points et
en moins de 3 minutes
premier point le privé c'est le recteur
qui distribue les moyens du privé donc
dans mes échanges avec l'enseignement
privé il y a ce sujet là singulièrement
maintenant ou les
IPs sont devenus du domaine public et
montrent que entre le public et le privé
il y a des différences importantes donc
moi mon dialogue avec les directeurs
diocésain c'est ouvrait des up de ça et
on progresse on progresse sur ce sujet
là le deuxième sujet c'est que vous avez
raison il y a pas à une sorte d'aller au
food il y a des différences absolument
incroyables je le souvenir d'avoir
rencontré des élèves qui étaient
d'anciens guerriers
à dire à 7-8 ans ils avaient porté des
fusillés ils avaient tiré et cela on les
scolarisé c'était pas forcément
complètement facile donc il y a tout il
y a toutes les types de situations le
troisième sujet c'est quand il y a 30
enfants allophone qui arrive dans une
école de sang et bien la question c'est
pas forcément celle des moyens la
question c'est celle de l'accompagnement
des équipes avec des gens qui jusque là
savaient pas faire et qu'il faut essayer
d'accompagner pour qu'il sache faire et
c'est pas forcément simple vu qu'on soit
que ça a pu déstabiliser et quand en
question le quatrième sujet c'est celui
du vocabulaire alors je rejoins ce qu'a
dit Daniel Guillaume totalement il y a
le vocabulaire courant il y a le
vocabulaire scolaire et culturel
je vous situe l'anecdote c'est un DF
tout ce qui a de plus français il est en
cours d'histoire je suis dans la classe
parce que
je regardais ça à ce moment-là et le
prof d'histoire il fait les temples à
Athènes et Acropole etc et le gamin lit
le nom des temples sur l'Acropole et à
un moment il y Athéna Nike
parce que pour lui quand on voit nikae
bah ça renvoie pas à ça revoit pas la
victoire ça renvoie à une marque bien
connue donc
la question de l'acquisition du
vocabulaire culturel et de référence
n'est pas quelque chose qui concerne
uniquement les allophones mais tous les
élèves et c'est singulièrement
d'ailleurs lié à l'origine sociale et
culturel c'est un autre sujet mais c'est
très important ensuite je rejoins
totalement ce qui a été dit sur les
associations partout où il y a des
associations qui peuvent faire le trait
d'union entre les familles et l'école et
bien ça se passe plus facilement pour
nous
sur l'intégration par l'école et par le
sport frappait que depuis deux ans et
bien l'éducation nationale a dans son
giron jeunesse et sport et donc la
continuité scolaire périscolaire
extrascolaire en lien avec les élus
locaux est un sujet tout à fait
intéressant on se rappelle que dans les
années 50 l'intégration dans les mines
de population polonaise s'est faite par
echosportifs et saguièrement par le
football et puis le dernier point
pour préciser ce sénateur
le sujet qui se pose c'est qu'elle
l'accompagnement on est sur des élèves à
la sortie de la sortie des up2a ils sont
encore besoin d'un accompagnement
particulier ils ont encore besoin d'une
prise en charge particulière par
l'ensemble des professeurs qui parfois
ne sont pas conscients de la situation
j'espère avoir précisé ma pensée merci
monsieur Guillaume juste sur sur un
point qui prolonge un petit peu cette
considération et qui répondrait en même
temps à une question sur la formation
c'est précisément pour cette après up2a
que les enseignants en ont besoin y
compris je dirais avec une prise de
conscience du fait que ça fait partie de
leur mission au sein de l'éducation
nationale j'allais dire comme autant
glorieux de l'école de la République qui
s'est construite avec l'enseignement du
français bon et donc ça c'est un c'est
un premier point et j'insiste quand même
sur le fait que la différence entre
francophone et allophone et les pas non
plus étanche au sein de notre personnel
lui-même et donc j'ai pu constater à
divers égards que beaucoup d'enseignants
sont tout à fait sensibilisés à cette
question parce que ça renvoie des
dimensions personnelles pour eux donc là
c'est plutôt porteur d'espérance je
crois en termes de formation
alors je voudrais peut-être revenir sur
des questions compléter ce qui a été dit
par par le réacteur de Créteil Daniel
overlo concernant finalement
l'intégration hors l'école
intégrer les élèves allophones c'est
aussi travailler avec leur famille et je
rappelle que il y a le dispositif offre
qui nous permet d'accompagner les
parents qui deviennent des parents
d'élèves en plus d'être parents cette
question là elle joue aussi alors sur
l'apprentissage de la langue mais y
compris avec les familles alors ça
n'empêchera pas que comme
ça a été dit tout à l'heure les les
élèves savent très bien parler une
langue en fonction du contexte et de
leur interlocuteur malgré tout c'est
aussi une façon de favoriser pour les
familles l'intégration et la
compréhension culturelle et linguistique
de notre pays et donc favoriser la
réussite des élèves donc on joue aussi
sur la façon dont on accompagne les
parents dans ses apprentissages et bien
sûr on articule cela avec les
associations partenaires de l'école je
rappelle aussi que
notamment les dispositifs vacances
apprenantes ont permis d'accueillir dans
un cadre qui est très différent de celui
de l'école des élèves les élèves
Ukrainiens l'année dernière pendant les
vacances de printemps ce qui a donné ce
qui était une autre façon de les de les
intégrer dans un cadre culturel sportif
associatif
complémentaires de celui de l'école je
voudrais revenir sur une question qui
était liée à l'évaluation en sortie de
dispositif aujourd'hui nous
plutôt que la proposition du DELF qui a
été proposée par la Cour des condensants
en rapport nous souhaitons favoriser le
passage la présentation du diplôme de
compétences en qui permet d'évaluer le
niveau en français langue étrangère et
en français langue scolaire et langue
seconde avec les nuances qui ont été
évoquées tout à l'heure
pour que on puisse avoir toutes la
palette du tout premier niveau dans le
dans le référentiel de compétences
européen sur les sur les langues qu'il
n'y voit un qui est un niveau
élémentaire où on est capable de se
présenter avec des nuances très très
faibles jusqu'au niveau complètement
fluide et de de natif tels que tel que
on l'a au bout d'un certain nombre
d'années ça nous paraît préférable ça
nous paraît préférable d'abord parce que
il n'y a pas d'échec on a tous quelque
soit la langue un certain niveau en
langue y compris très faible
donc ça permet de se positionner sans
échec plutôt que d'avoir quelque chose
que l'on a ou que l'on a pas et par
ailleurs ça permet de construire la
suite puisque plus on est à des niveaux
élevés plus on va pouvoir donner de
l'accompagnement adapté à l'élève compte
tenu son niveau en français et s'il est
au contraire plus bas continuer à avoir
un étayage un accompagnement un
environnement sur ce ces apprentissages
du français renforcés
merci Madame
j'allais dire Monsieur le Préfet
m'excuser moi je vous en prie non mais
j'ai entendu en plus beaucoup de
témoignages qui me parlent beaucoup faut
pas croire que à la Cour des comptes en
soi
inconscient ou en tout cas
insuffisamment conscient de ce qu'est la
réalité du terrain mais surtout
on voit qu'au travers de cette demande
du du Sénat au travers d'essayer
d'approcher une problématique
particulière on l'élargit très vite et
c'est normal derrière c'est la question
plus large de l'apprentissage du
français pas simplement d'ailleurs que
des enfants d'origine étrangère de
manière un peu plus large et puis de
leur intégration et tous les dispositifs
qui sont en place alors si je reviens à
la demande particulière et ces trois
points sur lesquels je souhaiterais
insister demande particulière sur les
élèves allophones donc pour nous on l'a
compris pour les élèves qui sont
nouvellement arrivés sur le territoire
on a et c'était toute la difficulté et
vraiment ça met en lumière ces
difficultés de l'exercice qui nous avait
été demandé si on a d'abord un problème
d'identification on a vraiment un
problème d'identification si on n'a pas
des données fiables solides complètes il
est difficile de se prononcer et on voit
bien qu'il y a beaucoup de cas et si on
veut avoir une approche comme le
souhaitez monsieur Longuet une approche
très fine territorialisée auquel moi je
suis entièrement d'accord parce que
selon qu'on se trouve dans une zone
frontalière ou une zone rurale c'est pas
la même problématique en zone urbaine on
voit bien que des sujets sont différents
donc il faut absolument qu'on mette en
place des dispositifs pour avoir des
données sur lesquelles on puisse
travailler avec un vrai suivi cohort
c'est des questions élémentaires qui
sont-ils si après on veut se poser la
question Que sont-ils devenus qui
sont-ils sur qui sont-ils et ben là il y
a beaucoup de trous dans la raquette je
entièrement d'accord et quand on voit et
les témoignages l'ont dit que quand on
met en place des dispositifs on envoie
apparaître qu'il n'était pas là pour de
multiples raisons des questions
d'environnement familial de mobilité il
y a beaucoup de raisons qui font que on
les a pas on les a pas repérés on les a
pas dans l'écran radar et souvent
d'ailleurs au niveau des rectorat ils
disposent des éléments il faut
recueillir ces éléments il faudrait
effectivement qu'il y ait des
dispositifs un peu plus pilotés au
niveau national puis sur lesquels on
puisse travailler donc ça c'est pour
nous c'est absolument indispensable donc
ensuite ce poste quand même la question
des dispositifs qui ont été mises en
place les dispositifs surtout qu'on fait
un peu de comparaison avec ce qui se
passe à l'étranger on voit qu'à
l'étranger ils ont des dispositifs qui
s'inscrivent dans la durée progressif
nous on a mis des dispositifs très
ponctuels un an deux ans et on voit bien
que si on met des dispositifs qui
permettent un soutien linguistique parce
que c'est pas au bout de deux ans
certains au bout de deux ans vont
vraiment rapidement maîtriser d'autres
vont rencontrer des difficultés si on
veut véritablement les aider à maîtriser
la langue et ensuite à trouver toutes
leurs places dans notre beau pays être
intégrés et bien sûr il y a toute la
question de la famille des associations
il y a pas que l'école il y a pas que
l'école qui doit y contribuer ça suppose
qu'on leur offre des dispositifs qui
s'inscrivent dans la durée autre point
sur lequel je insister qui est très
important c'est les enseignants on fera
rien si on n'a pas des enseignants et
moi je suis désolé quand on voit qu'il y
a 8% des enseignants qui disent qu'ils
sont pas préparés à s'occuper d'enfants
et d'élèves à la fin ça pose question ça
veut dire qu'il faut peut-être qu'on les
motive davantage alors il y a
différentes manières de les motiver par
la rémunération par des formations
adaptées etc et avec d'autres
difficultés que j'ai eu à connaître en
ayant discuté monsieur overlo aussi la
volatilité d'enseignants qui sont là
deux trois ans et qu'il naturellement se
disent pourquoi investir sinon de trois
ans je vais ailleurs il n'empêche il y a
un vrai sujet sur la formation des
enseignants ça et le rapport le mec
clairement en évidence et je crois que
ça il faut y travailler et enfin quand
même l'évaluation pardon on n'a pas un
indicateur comment évaluer tout ce qu'on
met en place là il faut des indicateurs
on a besoin de mettre en place des
indicateurs et moi je veux bien qu'on
discute longtemps sur est-ce qu'il faut
un DELF ou un diplôme mais d'abord le
sujet c'est aujourd'hui c'est facultatif
si on veut pouvoir faire une évaluation
faut que ce soit obligatoire si on reste
sur des diplômes qui sont facultatifs on
pourra pas faire d'évaluation donc là
aussi il faut qu'on s'entende les
nuances sur les diplômes je veux bien
les entendre mais ce qui est important
c'est est-ce que derrière on va avoir
des indicateurs fiables des indicateurs
solides robustes sur lesquels on va
pouvoir véritablement construire une
évaluation et là on aurait pu répondre
encore mieux à la demande de nos
parlementaires merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur spécial
pour conclure en 30 secondes monsieur le
Président
nous n'avons pas assez traité les
problèmes géographiques spécifiques je
pense à Mayotte et à la Guyane qui sont
quand même des sujets majeurs et qui se
peuvent se traduire comme cela a été
évoqué par nos collègues par l'éruption
de transafghanistan dans un village mais
là c'est massif l'aspect géographique et
mérite d'être bien évalué
et puis alors il y a deux
de données fortes et permanentes de
l'enseignement qui me réjouissent parce
que on les retrouve à l'occasion du
traitement et de l'accompagnement des
allophones la première cette première
idée force c'est que l'enseignement
c'est long et que le temps le langage en
vous écoutant le langage de la
scolarisation
n'est pas le langage de la socialisation
et en particulier de la profondeur qui
permet des perspectives universitaires
et là je crois qu'il faut être très pour
tous les élèves et c'est pour ça que ma
conviction personnelle et que
l'apprentissage du français de la langue
française de la lecture française de
l'écriture française est un devoir
absolu parce que c'est la meilleure
façon de d'approfondir ses propres
connaissances et de pouvoir comprendre
les gens plus compliqués qui nous
apprennent des choses passionnantes le
deuxième
élément fort c'est que vous l'avez dit
Madame sont pas des
parents des parents d'élèves
tout simplement que la famille est
indispensable au succès des enfants
c'est la raison pour laquelle je défends
la politique familiale par conviction
mais je n'ouvrirai pas ce débat à cet
instant simplement ça me fait plaisir de
le dire
si ça vous fait plaisir monsieur le
rapport de spécial il faut pas s'en
priver voilà
mais merci en tout cas merci Monsieur
abatta spécial d'avoir nous avoir permis
de lancer ce sujet
tu as peut-être pour beaucoup d'entre
nous un peu un peu loin et donc cette
audition en tout cas nous permet d'en
savoir beaucoup plus sur ce sujet merci
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur le
Recteur merci Madame le chef de service
d'être venu à cette audition et merci à
la cour pour le travail réalisé bonne
journée et bien sûr nous autorisons la
publication de l'enquête de la Cour des
comptes en annexe au rapport
d'information du rapporteur spécial sauf
des accords dans la salle que je ne vois
pas
merci encore